product pricing is a masterful
psychological manipulation technique
that we're exposed to on daily basis
from simply picking up a gallon of milk
for $1.99 to pre-ordering an iPhone for
$9.99 we try to make buying decisions
based on value use and longevity but
despite our best efforts these pricing
games subconsciously affect all of our
buying decisions
considering this how exactly our
products priced
[Applause]
starting off we have the most blatant
pricing technique charm pricing charm
pricing is when the price ends in 99 or
95 charm pricing is less about the
ending number and more about reducing
the leading number by one this is
especially effective for prices that are
just under a new place value like 10 100
or 1000 dollars our brains use the first
number as an anchor and used this to
perceive the cost of the certain product
when we see the price $1.99 the anchor
value is one rather than two despite the
actual cost being nearly two dollars by
reducing the perceived cost companies
are able to make their product seem like
a greater value test increasing the
likelihood of a conversion next up we
have exclusive pricing logically we want
the best value for the cheapest price
but in practice we often prefer getting
exclusive product for a higher price the
best example of this is Apple they don't
offer the best specs or the latest
technology in fact they often lag behind
the market whether it's a LED
implementation or ddr4 Ram but this
doesn't stop Apple from selling millions
of iPhones and Mac books the thing is
Apple isn't selling your phones or
laptops for selling a lifestyle and a
social image people are well aware of
how expensive Apple products are and
owning an Apple product will display
that you are financially stable and even
wealthy and this perceived image is what
sells Apple products as well as all
luxury brands our Rolls Royces really
four times as luxurious as Mercedes s
classes our organic foods really twice
as healthy as normal food and after
designer brands this really needs an
explanation
overall with premium pricing companies
try to get consumers to buy their
products based on exclusivity rather
than value moving on let's take a look
at a few visual tactics riding prices in
a small font is a popular technique used
by many companies our brains perceive
cost of a product not just by numerical
value but also its physical size
conversely discounters products
have large physical price tags as this
is perceived as a larger discount
speaking of larger prices you may have
noticed at large prices generally don't
have commas this is designed to
influence the way we coop the numbers in
a price if there was a comma we are more
likely to read this number as 2399 but
without a comma
we are aspired to read it as $23.99 by
associating smaller numbers with larger
prices companies make their products
appear cheaper than they really are
similar to this companies also share
words that mean small with high priced
products for instance if you were trying
to sell a $1500 phone instead of
advertising as high performance and high
capacity which are characteristics
consumers would already expect it is
much more effective to say 10 versatile
and low power consumption another
pricing technique used is breaking up
the total price of product into smaller
quantities this is especially popular
with monthly plans whether subscriptions
or installment payments for example a
gym that charges nine dollars a month
may advertise her subscription cost as
just three dollars a day this doesn't
sound nearly as bad and makes it seem
like a per visit cost is only three
dollars but the thing is it is unlikely
you go every single day the average
person would be lucky if they went just
ten times a month so the per visit cost
is actually three times more at nine
dollars similarly most gyms don't even
offer a nearly subscription because you
are less likely to renew given a higher
upfront cost following up for large
prices it is very effective to offer
specific pricing rather than round
numbers for example it's better to price
a car at twenty nine thousand six
hundred fifty four dollars and 37 cents
rather than just simply twenty eight
thousand nine hundred ninety nine cents
though you're offering a higher MSRP the
higher price is more likely to lead to a
sale this is because people associate
specific numbers with honesty they think
since you went through a trouble to come
up with a specific price you're not
trying to rip them off and so they're
less likely to negotiate the
around 28,000 $999.99 is perceived as
having a much larger markup
despite actually being cheaper however
in cases where purchase is emotional it
can actually be helpful to choose ground
numbers this is often the case in
jewelry in such cases the buyer has
already decided to buy the product
whether a wedding ring or a wedding
dress here people's budgets are much
more flexible and they choose to buy a
product based on how much they like the
product rather than the price as a
result you want the prices seem higher
as this is one of the few cases that
people are actually proud to pay more as
people are proud of these purchases as
you can see the psychology of pricing is
a very complex subject as a rules and
strategies vastly differ based on the
price emotions and a product itself
sometimes you want round numbers
sometimes you want specific numbers and
other times you want charming numbers
similarly sometimes you're selling value
while other times are selling
exclusivity or emotions but these are
some of the most commonly used pricing
strategies across all price ranges and
all companies use a combination of them
so next time you're shopping take a
closer look at the price because I
assure you there is more going on than
what meets the eye if you guys thought
this video gave a good overview of the
psychology of pricing then make sure
drop a like and consider subscribing to
see more questions logically answered
but until then I'm hari I'll see you
guys on the next one